i wanted to get into a dark story we'll
try to keep family friendly but i want
to i want to open up this uh this very
disturbing segment by um just letting
you suraj know did you know that luke's
been to epstein island
and what
that's the right response that's a good
response what capacity this always
happens all the time it's so frustrating
so who was the first person who like
reacted negatively right the point was
that after the raid everything was
cleared luke got in a speed boat was
like filming you know island and stuff
but when you tell people luke's been to
epstein island they immediately go like
oh when like
well allegedly after he he pre or post
he died
and
you know when there was that video
footage from that drone coming out
allegedly showing someone that looked
exactly like epstein on epstein island
after he allegedly killed himself that's
when we decided to take the speed boats
jump on the island and kind of film and
see whatever we could get from uh that
particular
nasty horrible location where atrocities
were committed i like that pre or post
yeah we got we okay so so
i i like to do you know we'll get a
little humor in there and make everybody
laugh on a dark subject because this
story is going to screw you up
from fox news
cnn producer accused of child
crimes
once decried growing news stories of
child abuse cases in old tweets new day
producer john griffin faces up to life
in prison according to this report
i'm trying to keep it family friendly
for you guys who might be having kids
nearby because this is dark stuff he
worked shoulder to shoulder with chris
cuomo
he paid a woman three thousand dollars
to bring her nine-year-old daughter to
his home
where he committed a very serious
atrocity against that child and that's
what he's accused of and i do think it's
fair to say even in the most heinous of
crimes crimes we must recognize and it's
until until proven guilty but these are
very
disturbing accusations against somebody
working high level at cnn we also have
had a bunch of other stories too that i
wanted to briefly mention you know the
cia who was uh who was soliciting
children
and they didn't want to prosecute him
because they were worried about state
secrets and then of course the very
obvious elephant in the room epstein
which has not yet been resolved but
everyone knows and so the issue i have
is it's really fascinating to me that if
you follow the establishment they'll
tell you there's a conspiracy theory
that powerful elites are abusing
children and trafficking them and sure
yeah some of it is out there crazy
conspiracy stuff like you know vampiric
global elites are like exsanguinating
babies to like live forever or something
which is a gross exaggeration of people
who do get blood transfusions to try and
increase their health or whatever but
the reality is more and more stories are
coming about high-ranking media
establishment elites who are abusing and
that's not committing atrocities against
children that's called atrocities
all of them yep no no no well you're not
pro wood chipper i'm not no we gotta
lock them up we gotta lock them up
man this has been going on not even just
a little wood chipper
it's like it's like okay
when you get into a massive amount of
power do you go crazy because you're
like i am now in control of the slave
ship i decide who lives and dies i'm
insane now and so they tend towards this
behavior like what these people are
doing to kids or yeah or is it that
those people
or i mean it's not natural it's not
natural to do that it seems
i don't know man you study history of
like humanity like girls were getting
married when they were 12 10 1 000 years
ago a lot of people gain a lot of power
and a lot of money and a lot of it goes
to their head there's megalomania
there's people literally having god
complexes if you look at jeffrey epstein
he was into population control eugenics
like a lot of very powerful people are
now this kind of cnn cia connection uh
doing horrible things to children is is
not rare as of course there have been
many instances when this has been
happening with very powerful people uh
including a lot of people that are
connected to the royal family that were
doing similar actions that are
absolutely unspeakable and horrible we
have jimmy seville we have the prime
minister of the united kingdom
previously beforehand caught red-handed
doing unspeakable things mainline
celebrities but hold on i just want to
make this one final one here i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna stop your kind of
thought i'm just going to add one thing
there's a photo of epstein at the
queen's cottage yes but it's not just
that it's not just that it's not just
epstein and gallant at
uh you know and there's also kevin
spacey uh hanging out at specific areas
that only the queen's allowed to be in
so it's kevin spacey glenn maxwell
jeffrey epstein but there's also photos
of galen maxwell pictured with jeff
zucker's wife jeff zucker is the the
chairman ceo of cnn and glenn maxwell is
pictured many times with his wife
there's also pictures of galen maxwell
and the founder and the owner of the
atlantic the atlantic just wrote a piece
that was entitled the great fake child
uh blank expletive
um
the the fake epidemic that's not
happening and they wrote an article
about how this is all not happening uh
just recently during the middle of the
gelane maxwell case which is absolutely
absurd to say the least and to see the
owner of the atlantic uh with galen
maxwell to see glenn maxwell with jeff
zucker's wife to see elaine maxwell with
so many other powerful people now it
could be glenn maxwell just storming in
taking a photo there i'm not here
looking to to make any judgments here
correlation does not prove causation but
there sure is a lot of coincidences
there sure is a lot of these very
powerful people that do work together
that do have similar uh actions that are
unspeakable to children that deserve to
be called out for that deserve to be
held accountable for that people deserve
to be at least in prison for the rest of
their lives for the horrible actions
that they committed against children and
a lot of these crimes are not persecuted
a lot of these crimes the people who did
the horrible things they're able to get
away with them and that to me is the
biggest injustice because in a lot of
these cases your tax dollars are paying
for the for these people's protection
that's absurd i have to say so i i'm
never going to run for president
but if i did my main platform would be
wood chipper
we've got to lock people up we've gotta
lock them up forever more people need to
be imprisoned for a longer amount of
time and many other people should not be
imprisoned for non-violent offenses i
you know for
for people who commit crimes against
children
in that particular manner
prison's not good enough for them
prison's too good for this you're saying
death penalty
that's the only time
wood chipper
i'm just not i'm i'm just not i'm just
anti-death penalty man i mean no no
don't get me wrong i'm i'm anti-death
penalty too but for this group of people
but this particular one i'm making this
and you know the thing too is like i
really think the prison system doesn't
work but for people who abuse kids i
think we need a special place to
lock them up excuse me yeah a lot of
times like dean island when people leave
prison i don't know if the numbers they
they enjoy that island so i'd rather oh
no i meant like it's only them though
maybe like the base of a volcano
maybe a place of a volcano it seems like
prison doesn't make people not pedo like
if someone's a child abuser they go to
jail it doesn't seem to make them not a
child abuser anymore like they get let
back out and i don't know what the
recidivism is exactly well they sure
face a lot of punishment a lot of people
who do hurt children when they do end up
in jail face very very tough
circumstances by other prisoners who
make sure that they face the full
ramifications for their crimes and
atrocities now the problem is there's
there's other people who are falsely
accused so you know that brings up a
very interesting you know question and
dynamic to to everything but when people
who do hurt children go to jail they
have one of the worst times imaginable
the stories that come out of people who
do that are um are absolutely crazy and
we and look like i said even the most
heinous crimes the cnn producer
still innocent until proven guilty right
then and yes the uh extenuating you know
i believe in our justice system i
believe that you know forensic evidence
will prove
guilt
or innocence
well you never present prove in a sense
well i'm sorry they are always apologies
that's right misspoke do you proves
guilt do you support the death penalty
luke um it's it's something that i
haven't um
come to a conclusion on it's very hard
to make that kind of um
that kind of call based on each
circumstance based on the situation it's
hard to just generalize that kind of
concept and idea because
um it's something that i need more time
to i have to say
part of me was trolling a little bit
because yes i am actually very
anti-death penalty i mean for example i
don't think the state should have the
right to kill somebody oh for sure you
don't give that power to the state it's
actually
you're letting him play god there there
i should very very much clarify that
statement right there are certain
circumstances war conflict um defense of
others obviously i just mean like
empowering the state to decide they can
end someone's life right i think we you
convict someone you go through due
process then you can you know
lock them up like on the real like i'm
definitely anti-death penalty and i'm
with you on that you know lock them up
and yeah never and and i think that as
you were saying luke yes people who
commit crimes against children they
definitely have the worst experience in
prison so i'm perfectly okay with that
but you know what chipper i think i tend
to support the death penalty my whole
life i've supported the death penalty
but
i mean
why why support the death penalty
because i think some people are so
deranged and damaged animals that they
are just a detriment to our species well
okay so let's do a vote right now how
many of how many of you here think ian
is being a detriment to us and we should
have the right to end his life i think
we should take away his phone oh see
there you go so look and that's my segue
today
my point is my point is
to be an individual
to have your own life liberty pursuit of
happiness and then to have the majority
just to say we decide what morality is
and our morality dictates we as the
majority can vote for the end of your
life i say that that's just absolutely
incorrect i mean you can't do that
that's the history of our species and
that's wrong tossing people out and
that's wrong because what's going to
happen is you're going to get a bunch of
locusts who are gonna be like you said a
hate speech off with his head perfect
speech what about when one guy's like
eating all the tribe's food and you're
like stop and he's like it's called
tying up his hands and being like so you
can't use your hands yeah and he's like
okay well you so then you let him go and
he does it again so then you kick him
out of the tribe then he raises an army
and comes back and kills everyone and
takes the truth like at what point are
you just sitting in the bud that's
ridiculous just because someone is
exiled i mean they're gonna raise an
army that's what napoleon did he got
exiled and then when he came back all
those old generals joined him again and
then he sounds like his old generals
were friends with him yeah sounds like
he never lost his the support from the
front should the french have executed
him when they arrested him the first
time after he you know no really you
don't think so dude i don't believe in
the death penalty i think how about if
they didn't exile him and they put him
in in the uh was the bastille
they didn't want to martyr him so they
exiled him and they just locked him up
that they didn't want to martyr him they
thought that if they
so
what you're saying is that so what
you're saying is that osama bin laden is
still alive and that he's being called
in the cia blacks
because the the united states did not
want to martyr him yes
i believe yes
you know that's why they
that's why they
they followed strict uh islamic protocol
and dumped him into the water yeah right
which obviously is never in any kind of
islamic script or understanding i i
don't i don't even necessarily agree
with imprisonment with to a certain
extent like i think if the community
decides you are a threat or a danger to
others then exile is
the right way to do things the problem
is in in the modern world it's
impossible to do yeah yeah because
everything's controlled by somebody
there's an interest everywhere there's
tons of people so all they can really do
is say and we can't let you go because
no one else is going to be happy if we
do that so we're going to lock you in a
box forever and i'm like
i'm not a big fan
of
that you know of like 10 people saying
we believe you did x therefore we can
take away your life liberty pursuit of
happiness because those people often are
wrong
they're more often correct like a jury
of your peers you know i think for the
most part our our legal our judicial
system does a good job of protecting
innocence but a lot of innocent people
go to prison and
i i agree with uh you know ben frank the
founding father's view on
the right of the of this the accused to
be innocent they are innocent until
proven guilty in that
if people believe
that the state at any point without
reason can strip them of their rights
then they have no they have no reason to
believe and and and and adhere to that
system meaning if it gets to a point
where people are just like why bother
they could arrest me anyway might as
well shoplift right why why bother
playing by the rules if they're not
going to play by the rules either and
that's where we're going and that's
freaky to me we're at a point now where
we can see hillary clinton thirty
thousand emails deleted nothing happens
well yeah i mean we're heading in that
direction already because
and again
the more information that we're exposed
to the more we understand that the game
is stacked against us or rigged
and
basically
we're you know it's a big club and you
ain't in it mm-hmm we're not in it i'm
thinking about all that oil oh tim you
might be in it i i don't know maybe what
what does it what does it mean to be in
the club
i don't know you tell me you're in the
club
i don't think i'm in the club i think
just just like
you get the same medical treatment as
congress does that nobody knows about it
that's true
yeah that could be one of them well i'll
put it this way there's a crab
there's a barrel full of crabs and i'm
the crab on top of that barrel trying to
climb its way out yeah and everybody's
you know you know you know crabs in a
barrel and yeah
i think you're in tier three club
there's a bunch of crabs outside the
barrel they're doing that crab dance
dinner
and then there's intention that's
congress and ceos and global elites and
all stuff yeah that's the tier two club
is like the elon musk and those people
and then the tier one clubs like davos
and uh i don't know
foreign relations yeah yeah yeah i would
i would i would agree that like elon
musk is powerful but i don't think he's
davos powerful i mean he might be the
richest guy in the world that doesn't
mean a whole lot like it means he's the
richest guy in the world he can buy a
super yacht yeah but he's working on
he's working on ai technology he's
working on microchips inside of human
brains so he might be especially with
how much power technologically he
develops so it could change at any
moment he he has enriched himself a lot
recently and he made some very
interesting comments against the vaccine
mandates uh just a couple of moments ago
which i think are very important what
did he say so do you want to are we
going to talk about that we're going to
talk about the list okay i was going to
add one more thing about the death
penalty to us gives give some
agreement to ian because some people are
chatting some good points um one point
is the state does that have the right to
end someone's life in self-defense or in
defense of others as a person does as
well and there's an argument that
through due process the state has
determined for the safety of the
community this person cannot be you know
confined or held it's just too dangerous
and so thus this is you know how some
people justify the death penalty i i
don't agree
because the the the risk of the state to
callously and incorrectly execute the
innocent is too great for me to support
a system in which the state is
authorized to end life dude in the age
of deep fakes like if someone gets
caught like committed uh accused of a
crime that they didn't commit but
there's a deep fake of them doing it
that's gonna be just terrifying oh man
and then you're gonna have but but it's
beyond that
you're gonna go to court and you're
going to have a prosecutor
stand up there and say ladies and
gentlemen of the jury
the defendant used hypertext markup
language through the hypertext transfer
protocol to gain access to information
that you would not be able to get access
to and the jury's gonna go
maximum sentence
anybody understand what i just said i
said he's gonna type in a url i was
gonna type in a web address but i
witnessed this happen
to some degree in the trial of weave
back when he was being prosecuted
because someone he knew
entered a url and got an email address
and then he said let's send it to
journalists the feds prosecuted him on
this and it was hilarious to hear the
prosecutor explain
during a sentencing why he should be
locked up forever because he used hyper
text markup language through the hyper
hypertext transfer protocol to get
access to people's private information
why should he have the right to use his
knowledge and power against us and i was
just like bro he literally just told the
court that some dude typed in to google
some words
and now we should go to prison for it
and people regular people don't get this
yeah it's not even about defects it's
about
ex like we're beyond the point where a
regular person can understand every
system
you know what i mean yeah and when the
prosecutor is more focused on winning
the case than
justice that's a problem i mean imagine
facing off with state prosecutors like
bingor and kamala harris going against
you knowing that you're innocent and
still
arguing to keep you in jail or to punish
you for a crime that you didn't commit
and there have been innocent people that
have been sent to jail that didn't
commit any crimes and there also has
have been people who have been
sentenced to death and killed by the
state that were innocent and never
committed the crimes that they were told
to have committed so there's instances
of that as well that we need to
recognize and this is already without
the deep fake technology that you were
talking about ian thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you